SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
BUSY NIGHT ON "HANNITY," WE ARE
GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, PSYCHO AND
TIED TRUMP RAGE, IT GOES FULL
BOUND.
NADLER, PELOSI AND COMPANY WANT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES TO ACTUALLY BREAK
THE LAW OR THEY ARE GOING TO
HOLD HIM IN CONTEMPT.
THAT IS HOW TWISTED THEY HAVE
NOW BECOME.
DEMOCRATS WANT WILLIAM BARR TO
REVEAL SECRET INFORMATION FROM
THE MUELLER REPORT OR HE WILL FC
THE MUELLER REPORT OR HE WILL FE
CHARGES FROM CONGRESS.
IF HE DID IT, IT IS ILLEGAL.
IT IS A FEDERAL VIOLATION UNDER
RULE 62 REVEAL GRAND JURY
INFORMATION.
THEY ARE LAWMAKERS, SHOWING THAT
THEY KNOW THIS?
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHERE
WE ARE WITH THIS.
AS WE SPEAK, A FULL, COMPLETELY
UNREDACTED COPY OF THE MUELLER
REPORT IS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
AT THE TOP DEMOCRATS CAN VIEW
WITH ONLY TWO FULL AND SEVEN
PERSONAL LINES REDACTED.
THAT'S IT.
THAT PROTECT GRAND JURY
INFORMATION AS PURSUE TO THE
FEDERAL LAW.
NEITHER NADLER NOR PELOSI OR ANY
OTHER DEMOCRAT FOR THAT MATTER
HAS EVER BOTHERED TO VIEW THE
REPORT.
SO ALL OF WHAT THIS IS IS A
CIRCUS.
IT IS A SIDESHOW, A TOTAL LACK.
AND IT IS JUST MORE LIES AS I
HAVE SAID, THE MUELLER ISSUE IS
OVER.
IT IS DONE.
IT IS FINISHED.
THIS THAT REMAINS IS MERELY
NOISE.
AND HANK JOHNSON ACCIDENTALLY,
WELL, STUMBLED ON THE TRUTH AND
SPILLED THE BEANS AND I MADE IT
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL ABOUT.
A RARE MOMENT OF VERITY.
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS ALL PART OF THE
COVER-UP.
AND IT IS UP TO THIS COMMITTEE
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THAT
REPORT, BECAUSE WE HAVE A LAWFUL
RESPONSIBILITY CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENGAGE IN,
ONE OF WHICH IS POSSIBLY
IMPEACHMENT.
HOW CAN WE IMPEACH WITHOUT
GETTING THE DOCUMENTS?
>> Sean: IT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS
THE SUBPOENA AND SUBSEQUENT
CONTEMPT TO VOTE, JUST A BLATANT
POLITICAL GAME, A CIRCUS FROM A
GROUP OF WELL, PEOPLE, WHO HAVE
CONNED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
YEARS WITH LIES AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
TRUTH, JUSTICE, IT MEANS NOTHING
TO THEM.
LOOK AT HOW THE TOP DEMOCRATS
REACTED IN 2012 WHEN OBAMA'S
SELF-PROCLAIMED WING MAN,
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER WAS
HELD IN CONTEMPT AFTER REFUSING
TO TURN OVER SCORES OF
SUBPOENAED DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
THE FAST AND FURIOUS SCANDAL.
BY THE WAY, A SCANDAL WHERE
AMERICANS AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
DIED BECAUSE OF THEIR STUPIDITY.
CONGRESSMAN NADLER'S RAGE, HE
TWEETED AGAINST A VERY THOUGHT
OF A CONTEMPT RULING IN THE CASE
"JUST JOINED THE #Walkout TO
PROTEST THE SHAMEFUL POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED G.O.P. VOTE HOLDING
THE AG HOLDER IN CONTEMPT.
HE DESERVED IT."
FROM THE VERY SAME PERSON WHO
JUST DEVOTED TO HOLD AN AG BAR
IN CONTEMPT, WHY, FOR NOT
RELEASING TWO LINES THAT HE MUS,
HE IS MANDATED BY LAW, LEGALLY
PROTECTED GRAND JURY INFORMATIO
INFORMATION.
YOUR HYPOCRISY WREAKS.
AND IT WAS NOT JUST NADLER, IT
IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF LUNATICS
THAT ARE KNOWN AS THE MODERN-DAY
EXTREME RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO BRANDES CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS AGAINST THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, IT IS
CONTEMPTIBLE.
THE RUSH THAT THEY ARE PUTTING
ON IT IS JUST INEXPLICABLE.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING, THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT WANT JOBS, THEY ARE
GOING ON A WITCH HUNT.
TO SPEAK OF THE PUBLIC MAJORITY
INTENDS TO BRING A CONTEMPT
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR AGAINST
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO SAY THAT THIS IS A TERRIBLE
USE OF CONGRESS' POWER AND TIME
IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE FACTS.
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS PLAYED >>
THEY HAVE NOT FOUND ANY EVIDENCE
THAT THIS ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
HIDING ANYTHING.
THAT HE HAD LIED TO ANYBODY.
THEY STILL DO NOT HAVE ANY FACTS
TO SUPPORT THIS ILLEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION.
>> TO OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES,
SHAME ON YOU.
[ALTOGETHER "SHAME ON YOU"]
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHA
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHT
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHE
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHW
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHG
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHI
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHT
>> Tucker: >> Sean: WHO
RANT TODAY?
IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
FAVORITE TOOL.
GOING OVER THE ALLEGATIONS OF
VIOLENT RATE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
AGAINST A DEMOCRATIC
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA,
INDIGNATION OVER A COMING TO AN
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHO ACTUALLY
WAS PERFECT IN A RESPONSE IN ONE
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
OF WHY HE WAS WEARING A RED MEGA
HAT.
NOTHING MORE THAN A YAWN OVER
THE GOVERNOR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF VIRGINIA
DRESSING UP IN BLACKFACE.
THEY ARE APOCALYPTIC, PANIC OVER
CLIMATE CHANGE, BUT THEY HAVE NO
PROBLEM FLYING IN AND OUT OF
THEIR PRIVATE JET HEADQUARTERS
AND RIDING AROUND IN THEIR
MASSIVE SUVs WITH OH, LET'S
SEE, PEOPLE TO GUARD THEM WITH
GUNS.
AND WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
THEM.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET ANGER FROM
THE 1 PERCENT FROM A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE WHO CALLS
HIMSELF A SOCIALIST.
YES, THAT GUY.
AND WORST OF ALL, THE SELECTIVE
MORAL OUTRAGE SURROUNDING
SO-CALLED RUSH OF COLLUSION.
BECAUSE FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS
DEMOCRATS, THEIR BODIES IN THE
MEDIA MOB, THEY PERPETUATED
NOTHING BUT LIES, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, A TOTAL HOAX ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ALL WHILE TOTALLY IGNORING REAL
COLLUSION RIGHT IN FRONT OF
THEIR EYES.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW BY NOW,
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN LIES USING A FOREIGN
SPY, PUTTING TOGETHER A DOCUMENT
THAT HE DOES NOT EVEN STANDBY
WITH PROPAGANDA, MISINFORMATION,
LIES LEAKED TO THE PRESS.
WHY?
TO RIG THE ELECTION IN HILLARY'S
FAVOR.
DID I SAY WITH RUSSIAN LIES?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SUGGESTING
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY PART OF A
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
ALL ALONG.
AND THAT DID NOT STOP THE PHONY
DOSSIER FROM BEING WEAPONIZED BY
OUR OWN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND THE DOSSIER OFFER
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, I THOUGHT TA
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, I THOUGHT TT
THEY WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS?
STEELE HAD HIS PAINTED
PROPAGANDA WITH MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUALS INSIDE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, HIGH RANKING DOJ
OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR WARNED
EVERYBODY IN THE DOJ AND THE FBI
THAT STEELE WAS BEING FUNDED BY
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
SHE WAS PAYING FOR ALL OF IT.
AND THAT HIS INFORMATION, HER
INFORMATION SHE PAID FOR WAS
UNVERIFIED THAT STEELE HATED
TRUMP AND HILLARY PLAYED FOR IT.
THAT WAS AUGUST OF 2016.
JOHN SOLOMON FROM THE HILL WILL
JOIN US IN A MOMENT WITH MUCH
MORE BREAKING NEWS.
REPORTING THAT THE DEPUTY
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF STATE
KATHLEEN CADILLAC, WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT STEELE'S
RESEARCH WAS ALL POLITICAL.
THERE WAS AN END DATE, HE HAD AN
ELECTION DAY DEADLINE.
THE TEN DAYS LATER,
OCTOBER 21ST, OH, JIM COMEY,
MR. JIM.
2016, SIGNED OFF ON THE FIRST
FISA APPLICATION AGAINST CARTER
PAGE SWEARING THAT STEELE WAS
RELIABLE AND ACCURATE, AND THAT
HE VERIFIED THE BULK OF THAT
INFORMATION WHICH WAS HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES.
REMEMBER, THAT IS ON TOP OF THE
FISA APPLICATIONS.
HIS VERIFIED APPLICATION.
THE WORDS ARE RIGHT ON TOP.
AND TONIGHT, WE HAVE BRAND-NEW
JUST RELEASED HANDWRITTEN
DOCUMENTS UNCOVERED BY JOHN
SOLOMON.
THE INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SHOWING THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL KATHLEEN CATHOLIC
ACTUALLY SOUNDED THE ALARM ABOUT
STEELE TO THE HIGH-RANKING
MEMBERS OF THE FBI, JIM COMEY'S
FBI OVER A MULTITUDE OF ISSUES
ALL BEFORE THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION WENT IN.
NOT ONLY DID SHE REPORT THE
PARTISAN NATURE OF STEELE'S
RESEARCH BUT ACCUSED HIM OF
GIVING THE GOVERNMENT BLATANTLY
FALSE INFORMATION AND ALSO
LEAKING HIS MATERIAL TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST," ALL TOO
HAPPY TO OF COURSE PRINTED.
SHE RAISED ALL OF THESE CONCERNS
WELL BEFORE CHRISTOPHER STEELE
WAS THE CENTERPIECE OF THE FIRST
REQUEST OR APPLICATION
AGAINST TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATES CARTER PAGE, THUS
GIVING A BACKDOOR INTO ALL
THINGS TRUMP, ALL THINGS WERE ON
TRUMP, ALL THINGS TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
AND BREAKING MINUTES AGO, MARK
MEADOWS CONFIRMING THIS
INFORMATION WAS IN FACT
TRANSMITTED TO THE FBI.
MAYBE THAT IS WHY THE
SELF-AGGRANDIZING SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY IS TRYING HARD TO
RESHAPE THE NARRATIVE AND
ANOTHER PUBLIC APPEARANCE ON
FAKE NEWS CNN EARLIER TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THAT THE FBI SENT AN
INVESTIGATOR POSING AS AN
ASSISTANT TO MEET WITH THE TRUMP
AIDE GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS IN
2016, DOES THAT QUALIFY AS
SPYING?
>> YEAH, I WILL NOT COMMENT ON A
PARTICULAR INVESTIGATIVE STEP,
BECAUSE THAT IS FOR THE BOROUGH
TO DO.
I'M NOT IN THE GOVERNMENT
ANYMORE.
BUT THE FBI DOES NOT SPIKE TO
BEGIN WITH.
THE FBI INVESTIGATES.
SPEAK OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL ARE LOOKING
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE
INVESTIGATION, ARE YOU CONFIDENT
INVESTIGATION, ARE YOU CONFIDENY
INVESTIGATION, ARE YOU CONFIDENU
DID EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK
AND THAT THE FBI, THE PEOPLE
AROUND YOU DID EVERYTHING BY THE
BOOK?
>> YES, NO DOUBT IN MY MIND,
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT I AM
AGAINST REVIEW OF IT.
THAT IS TOTALLY FINE.
>> YOU THINK THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL FIND
NOTHING INAPPROPRIATE?
>> I DO NOT THINK SO.
BUT IF THEY DO, THEY DO.
THEY SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT.
>> Sean: HEY, JIMBO, YOU
SIGNED A FIVE'S APPLICATION TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE AND THE